when we get 35,000 subscribers we were
freaking out like we've won the lottery
that was two and a half years ago this
week we have officially passed five
million subscribers and we're like you
just blew my mind what does it all mean
banjo whoa that's amazing
or is it so possible that your head is
spinning like a top see we're still just
a couple of goofy movie fans look in the
mirror every morning and think
well who the hell are you talking to
talking to me oh wow damn you're gonna
say good night I better very lovely walk
out the door get in the car go home
jerk-off and that's all you gonna do and
bucks Toit oh oh I am successful I am
powerful I am handsome I am happy
successful powerful handsome happy then
I apply an herb mint facial mask which I
leave on for 10 minutes while I prepare
the rest of my routine this was your
idea George it's a good idea right
it's a good idea some days we wake up
and remember the YouTube channel and
think daddy don't you make like a tree
and get the five million is a number
large enough that we might not ever be
able to wrap our brains around it the
size is big really big you just won't
believe how vastly hugely mind-boggling
Liebig it is that's a virtual planet -
each has its own weather system but we
do know this we know who makes this
engine run it's you people you glorious
bastards you valiant Watchers of the
videos and to you we wanted to say I
don't think that I thank you ever for
what you've done for me
thank you for your sacrifice thank you
daddy
I love you hey Luke thanks thanks for
coming after me it's just basic
chemistry but thank you Jesse I'm glad
thank you I love you you complete me I
love you you kept me honest he made me a
whole person I owe you everything thank
you for doing this Ellen no seriously
from the bottom of our hearts thank you